-I'm so happy to see you,
Marc Maron.
-Nice to see you, too, man.
-We got a full audience here.
We're live, in person.
I mean, this is happening.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Marc Maron!
-The last time,
I was on my porch.
-That's right.
-Just sitting on the porch,
talking to you.
-You were Zooming me
and I appreciate that
because we needed guests.
-That was the best, man,
just not going anywhere.
[ Laughter ]
-No! This is the best.
-I'm doing "The Tonight Show"
on the porch.
[ Laughter ]
-No! This is the best.
You're doing "The Tonight Show"
-You're right here.
-in "The Tonight Show," yeah.
-You're right there!
-Right here!
-Oh, man.
-You look great!
-I dressed. I got dressed.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't get food on me.
Big day.
-Big day.
[ Laughter ]
You didn't get food.
You do. You look fantastic.
-I'm aging.
I don't know if you can tell,
but I'm --
[ Laughter ]
What are you laughing at?
-No.
-Why are they laughing, Jimmy?
-No one's laughing.
-But it's weird.
I don't know that
I'm getting older
because, like, okay,
I don't have kids.
And I think, if you have kids,
you can kind of see yourself
dying in your kids, you know?
[ Laughter ]
Because you're kind of like --
you're kind of like,
"Happy Birthday."
"It's happening.
Oh, my God!"
[ Laughter ]
Right? Mirrors, you know,
you get used to mirrors.
Like you can just
rationalize it.
You see yourself every day.
You do your poses
[ Laughter ]
and you don't tell.
You can't tell.
But if I see a picture, man,
if I see a picture of me,
it's like, "Oh, my God!
When did my head get old?
I got an old head!"
[ Laughter ]
-Old head?
-Yeah.
No matter what I do down here,
head's still old.
[ Laughter ]
Head's still old.
Like people are like,
"Nice jacket.
Old head."
[ Laughter ]
-You got an old head.
-I got an old head.
-Aside from getting older,
I mean,
you look good.
I mean, how do you feel?
-I'm alright. You know, I --
[ Laughter ]
Well, you know, I believe --
I think I'm wrong,
but I think I hide
my anxiety pretty well.
[ Laughter ]
-I think you do.
-Why are you laughing?
Why are you laughing?
-I'm not, no. I was thinking
about something else.
[ Laughter ]
-No, because I have tools.
I'm an anxious person.
I'm anxious.
I get filled with dread a lot,
but I've got some tools.
I'll share them.
Some other people,
maybe they're anxious.
About ten times a day,
I have to say this to myself --
"Dude, you're not in a hurry!
[ Laughter ]
You're not in a hurry!"
You know what I mean?
Because like
I'll wake up and be like,
"Oh, man, I gotta...!"
And like you have nothing.
There's nothing.
You have nothing.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You don't need to finish
the sentence.
"I gotta --"
No, you don't.
-You're coming into the day
a little hot.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. You don't gotta
do anything.
-No, no.
Just make the coffee.
I drink about a quart of coffee
[ Laughter ]
and then I just kind of like
caffeinate myself
into sort of an exhaustion.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
But you're back on tour.
Do you like going on tour?
-Well, yeah, I was just in --
I did Providence and Boston
and I did Tarrytown.
I did Portland, Maine;
Providence.
It's weird going back
to these places where I started
because my car got stolen
when I was doing a gig
in Providence in 1989.
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly. You don't forget
those things.
-No, you don't. And I went
to the police station.
They still haven't found it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-But it's good that they're
on it, still,
you know what I mean?
-They're still thinking
about it.
[ Laughter ]
-It's not like television.
These things take a while
to solve.
-"We can't help you, Marc."
But this is called
This May Be the Last Time Tour.
-Yes.
-Why?
-Why not? Does anyone know
what's going to happen?
[ Laughter ]
Am I wrong in thinking
that we're in trouble, maybe?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, don't we
all kind of know it?
I don't have any hope.
[ Laughter ]
But --
I mean, who has hope?
What are you, seven?
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
-Magical thinking.
No, what I'm saying --
No, listen to me.
I do believe like
people will adapt. They will.
I think we're maybe
three years away
from hearing this
on the streets of New York --
"You know, 130's not that hot.
Once you get out in it,
you get used to it.
Just don't stay out there
past the allotted time --
30 minutes.
Bring a water pack. Be careful."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God. Hope not.
-Well, you know,
I don't know what to do.
Do you know what to do?
It seems like out of our control
and like we all know
that the environment is terrible
and we feel guilty about it,
but I think in the back
of our heads,
most of us are like,
"Well, you know,
that Swedish teenager has it
under control," you know?
[ Laughter ]
Like I don't want to --
-Greta Thunberg?
[ Applause ]
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-That's so funny.
I don't want to get
in the way.
I don't want to get in the way
of whatever Greta's doing.
She's young.
She's focused.
She's going to nail it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
We're going to be okay.
-That's really funny.
You get tickets
at wtfpod.com/tour.
-And get them there.
People just Google
"Mark Marion tickets"
and they're taken
to a scalper site immediately
and then they tweet at me,
go like,
"Why is it $900?"
[ Laughter ]
I'm like, "Why are you
so stupid?"
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, don't say that.
Let's talk
about "The Bad Guys."
You're in this new
animated film, "The Bad Guys."
You're the voice of Mr. Snake.
-That's correct.
-Now, what do you do?
What does Marc Maron do to get
into character for it?
-I've done a few
animated characters
and they're just different
degrees of me yelling.
[ Laughter ]
Like here, I'll do a couple
of my animated voices for you.
-Let me close my eyes.
-There's this guy!
How about this guy?!
-Yeah, I like him.
-And then, like,
"What are you doing?!"
[ Laughter ]
There's that guy.
Two totally different
characters.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. Isn't that amazing?
-Thank you.
-Right before your eyes.
[ Cheering and applause ]
You are very funny in this
and I want to show
everyone a clip.
Here's Marc Maron as Mr. Snake
in "The Bad Guys."
Take a look at this.
[ Siren wailing ]
-[ Chuckle ]
-Wolf,
what are you doing?
-What?
-Yeah!
-Oh, that!
I-I-I'm sorry.
I thought it was, uh, obvious.
We're going to go good.
[ Siren wailing ]
-You totally lost me.
-I told him to stop drinking
out of the toilet.
-Hey, did you get hit
on the head?
-What? No, I didn't.
-My cousin got hit on the head
with an anchor and, after that,
he only swam in a circle.
-No, no, guys, guys, guys.
You're not following me.
The bad guys become
the good guys
so we can stay the bad guys,
you know what I mean?
[ Laughter ]
-Bad guys acting good?
It's the ultimate bad guy thing!
It's fantastic!
Wolf, you're a genius!
[ Laughter ]
-That's exactly right.
-[ As Mr. Snake ] Fantastic.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Are you still --
-What?
-Are you still collecting vinyl?
Get any new vinyl?
-Yeah, I do. I still do
the vinyl thing.
I'd like to think that like
I discovered vinyl
before everybody else.
[ Laughter ]
Like I think when I started
buying records,
like two weeks later,
everyone in the world
started buying records.
[ Laughter ]
But here's the weird thing
about buying records, is,
if you go, if you're a guy
who shops at record stores,
it's usually guys my age,
you know, and,
[ Laughter ]
you know, you'll be in the
record store for about an hour
and, within that hour,
someone will walk in
that looks exactly like you.
[ Laughter ]
And you just have this moment
where you both look
at each other and go like,
"I don't know.
I don't know what's happened."
[ Laughter ]
And then I go, "I know.
it's weird, right?
But, hey, cool boots.
Old head."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Old head.
Marc Maron, everybody!
"The Bad Guys" hits theaters
this Friday.
Check out wtfpod.com
for information
on Marc's stand-up tour.
We'll be right back.